arrange the digits 2 6 0 and 1 so that
you create the highest possible four
digit number
so the way i like to think about it is i
want to if i'm trying to create as large
of a number as possible i want to put
the largest digits in the largest or the
largest numbers in the largest place
value so if it's a four digit number so
it's one two three four digit numbers
whatever i put here this is going to
represent
whatever i put here is going to
represent hundreds
whatever i put here represents tens and
whatever i put here represents ones so i
want to maximize the number of thousands
i have for example the largest number
here is six i could make it six thousand
i could make it six hundred i could make
it sixty or i could make it six well if
i want as large number of a possible as
possible i'm gonna make it six
six thousand notice if i put any other
number in that place value if i put 0
there i'd have no thousands if i put 2
there i only have 2 000. if i put one
they only have 1 000. 6000 is definitely
going to be bigger than any of the
numbers that could be constructed with
the 2 0 or 1 in the thousands place
now the exact same logic we want the
next largest number in the hundreds
place so the next largest number here is
a two so i'm going to put a two right
over here i'd rather have two hundreds
than zero hundreds or one hundreds
that's going to make it bigger
then same exact idea we want the next
largest number in the tens place i'd
rather have 110 than 010 and then we're
just left with the zero so we're just
gonna put the zero right over here so we
can make six thousand two hundred and
ten if i wanted to make the smallest
possible four digit number then i would
rearrange this so i have the smallest
possible number in the thousands and the
largest possible number in the ones so
the smallest possible number i could
create is 0
6.
let me be careful 0
0 1
6. so the smallest possible number if i
just switch this around would be 126
that i could construct out of these
digits but this is what they asked for
so give 6210